the Sony Walkman zx2 isn't like any
Walkman you've seen before it plays high
resolution audio files and will set you
back a whopping 1200 dollars this isn't
one for the casual listener zx2 itself
is really well made the metal body is a
textured leather back and a gold audio
jack not so subtly telling you that the
components inside are top of the line it
feels like a serious piece of audio
equipment but it's heavier and bulkier
than I'd like for daily use inside is a
128 gigabyte hard drive that you'll have
to expand pretty quickly with a microSD
card to hold those larger high
definition audio files the interface is
Android base but feels laggy at times
and while the physical buttons on the
side or a good idea practically they're
hard to get used to after years of only
using touch screens the real question
though is how the ZX two sounds
listening with a pair of quality
headphones on my couch or at my desk
music sounded incredible it was rich it
was textured and I loved it but the
moment I stepped out into the real world
any noticeable difference disappeared
there are just too many distractions and
too much ambient noise I love the idea
of a high-end gadget that does one thing
really well but considering the limited
audio benefits the burden of carrying
another heavy device and the steep price
I'm giving the ZX to a pass by a good
pair of headphones instead save that
extra cash for the next Taylor Swift
album